[Musique]
vous allez avait l'air aussi émerveillé
que ces gens regardant ce reportage
professeur albert jacquard oui ce qui
était merveilleux c'est la ferveur mais
en même temps en même temps c'est des
réactions très contrastées vous savez
dites moi quel dommage que cette ferveur
soit à propos d'une poupée alors qu'elle
pourrait être à propos d'enfants tous
vivants et que finalement peut-être
qu'ils sont en train de se tromper
d'objectif
j'ai très peur de ça non je voudrais pas
faire le de rabat joie cette
extraordinaire ce bonheur qu'ils ont
mais de penser qu'on a réussi sa vie
parce que on a obtenu sa non non non
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas imaginer
que c'est finalement une recherche en
soi un peu la cale il faut pas regarder
ça au premier au premier degré on
imaginer ce qu'ils vont chercher là
derrière sent bien que c'est une poupée
qu'une poupée ça ne fait pas vraiment
des miracles que les miracles vraiment
ça n'existe pas que par contre il y a
des choses extraordinaires que l'on peut
faire soi même et j'ai peur que ça serve
si vous voulez de déviation
alors qu'il aurait tant de choses à
faire dans ce monde des hommes et
puisque ça se passe au mexique il ya
tant de misères au mexique aux et
transmettre à un enfant tant de choses
que devrait une poupée dans tout ce que
des vrais enfants n'ont pas ça fait mal
quand même j -p en particulier très peur
de lien avec la religion je n'aime pas
la religion j'ai pas aimé que le curé
sens même si vous voulez c'est pas sa
place c'est pas ta place de la religion
et où ils se prétendent chrétiens
voiture est plutôt catholique non ils
sont pas chrétiens faisant ça je signale
qu'un curé d'ailleurs qu'ils avaient
essayé dans cette fameuse histoire du
ninon panne de récupérer la poupée parce
que justement ça lui déplaisait a été
renvoyée par l'évêché petite histoire
cette histoire mais non ça n'a rien à
voir avec la religion ça n'a rien à voir
ou font même avec une fois ou avec ou
avec surtout une addiction comment
comment vous chercheurs scientifiques
arrivez vous à concilier vos croyances
et d'ailleurs quels sont les vôtres avec
la science en d'autres termes dieu pour
vous est il compatible avec la science
je ne pouvais même pas la question non
quand le départ de croyance
parce que la science nous apprendre par
croire et nous apprend à regarder à
savoir que ce que l'on voit n'est jamais
qu'illusion a essayé d'expliquer ce qui
se passe dans ce que l'on voit de
comprendre que les modèles explicatifs
sont toujours à réviser par conséquent
la science ne croit à rien le
scientifique ne crois pas ils constatent
ils comparent ils vérifient tous les
bruits zaza car elle professeur jacquard
il en fait autant qu'en tant que
professeurs mais aussi en tant qu'homme
il a besoin de plus mais ce plus
j'aimerais ne pas le remplir avec une
fois ou avec des croyances au fond il ya
mieux que les croyances ya l'adhésion
pour moi qui suis de formation
catholique qui essaient de devenir
chrétien
être chrétien ne signifie pas du tout
accepté un credo je ne crois pas le
credo par contre ça consiste à adhérer à
une certaine parole il se trouve qu'un
homme il ya 2000 ans a dit des choses
que je trouve pas mal il a dit aimez
vous les uns les autres il fallait le
dire et à l'époque ce n'était pas du
tout évidente et il a dit ça et je
trouve que c'est la vraie la vraie
solution pour le monde de demain et par
conséquent pour moi être chrétien c'est
un des réels parole et pas
nécessairement croire un certain nombre
de choses je ne crois pas à la
résurrection des corps
je ne crois pas même à l'unicité de
saveurs khadir je ne crois pas que la
sainte vierge était vierge de tout ça je
m'en fiche complètement par contre je
trouve admirable qu'un homme ait pu dire
aimez vous les uns les autres et ce qui
manque dans ce reportage encore une fois
vous devez être un bon choix et où ils
ont une ferveur merveilleuse ce qui
manque justement c'est l'amour des
hommes les uns pour les autres nous
pensons tous un peu la même chose mais
intéressant à découvrir aussi vous êtes
d'accord avec moi un fait extraordinaire
bravo du loup montrer ça alors je
voudrais vous poser une autre question
maintenant pour en venir au deuxième
reportage deuxième voyage ou deuxièmes
rencontres que je vais vous faire faire
la curiosité est un trait de caractère
permanent chez vous depuis toujours
n'est ce pas il me semble que c'est la
caractéristique de l'homme peut toujours
se demander ce qu'il ya derrière
[Musique]